well we grab this guy and he starts
really getting angry and wrestling
around and well they've got pretty good
control of his upper half and I'm trying
not to get control of all of his lower
extremities and unfortunately things
start moving around a little too much
and I'm not sure if you ever been kicked
in the face by a one-year old I thought
you were gonna say by Pringles can dick
I can imagine that's what this thing
felt like is just like a one-year-old
leg just kicking me the whole time oh
hold on a
minute
you got to go around this big naked son
of a bitch's waist and the whole time
his dicks just Bea you in the face yeah
for a second there until I managed to
get a
repositioning without letting him go I
managed to get myself away from it and
not let him
go just getting pounded by a [__]
one-year-old leg in the
face the Honeydew with y'all subscribe
today